[Música]
eu vou poder me chama de beijo de sete a
mais chegará à bomba
[Música]
e aí galera o canal você olha só que
beleza hein delícia para cuiabá domingo
dia 23 tem aí no ginásio aecim tocantins
em 2011 dia 17 de maio rio de janeiro
reuniu 21 de março em são luís maranhão
4 de junho tem espaço das américas em
são paulo em olha só olha no site aí que
tem inclusive tem várias cidades foi
muito tempo eu fiz um vídeo imitando as
pessoas vão sempre pt mt gustavo lemos
um ponto que eles estavam mateus usina
agora não pare por aqui e que acabou
doenças hoje nas baladas a idéia da vida
que as pessoas vão que está rolando um
fator não fazer um videogame todos os
funkeiros pra você
vamos nessa civil porque temos sequer
viu tem uma particularidade na voz dele
eu nem sequer viu parece que tá tomando
um shopping é muito explosiva no méxico
ela não é muito do zimba não bacon ela
não
ai ai eu disse para ela tem vida própria
e eu tive que fará andré citando de quem
não tenha trabalho e vai devagar senão
ela fala se torna um cartão pode chegar
lá emicida haverá entre a vontade de ir
pra praia já passou sobre a cabeça bem
atenção no mc davi parece muita roda
jarlene por isso é obrigada poderia
estar matando roubando prefeito e só que
na versão homem é que a vontade de ir
pra praia já passou o verão está
chegando um tapa
é nesse geral as novinhas dançando
descendo de fio dental oya terminadas
com andré em maravilha lauda
imagina ela fazendo quadra de
sensacional
imagina ela fazendo quadrilha de olha
que minavam se casar
o iniciante china ou você prova está bem
atenção não parece um mundo que está
voltando a falar agora ao mundo você é
um homem acabou pra falar ele vai pedir
água ea pedir comida e vai falar me leva
no forno de hoje estando e não pode ser
algo pessoal já é seguro e sanchai ana
roxo era fome se berlim quando se pede
paz que ele canta hoje da pompéia e tem
que cantar alto sabiá tem que cantar
mesmo fim no mesmo alto padrão de renda
[Música]
[Aplausos]
na boca dele um bom ou um do mundo é
didático que enquanto ele tenta ensinar
as pessoas a separação silábica que o
tampa amiga e fã arrancada a galera tá
com a bmw entre eles josé braga tentava
depois que ele é o ludo fumtur de bebo
tá roubando abrindo nossa que dele tem
esse mali da uva até uma página muito
que ele preste o pai do bebê bonito lhe
parece que a qualquer momento vai dizer
sim com o mundo mais da aip qual bumbum
o edson é por mim da banda é verdade e
de idéia e agora fico pensando se a
música de funk fosse cantar por cantores
do sertanejo
quem é e será minha 2000
estava um vôo e rammstein não é novinha
e como o fluxo não vinha melhor sabe o
que quer
ela é ingênua menisco fiel do sul lugar
ai meu hotel ano
[Música]
avistei a novela black hawk na rolha
o
isto é novinho braga
é com ela que é fã
se você gostou do vídeo não se esquece
clicar gostei muita gente sabe o vídeo
sempre gostei que já está com outros
descarregar geralmente a pessoa fez
muitos vídeos mas não esquece que gostei
de você vai gostar de alguma dessas
limitações é claro que nem tudo que vai
agradar ninguém é perfeito não se limita
a todo mundo a gente faz que eu como
você vê essa amizade e do outro lado da
tela então clique em gostei comenta aqui
embaixo no youtube pelo time se você
quer que eu emiti outro sertanejo
qualquer do cantor do mundo que eu vou
tentar imitar pra você popular no
facebook não esquece é muito importante
está todo mundo esquece de fazer mas se
você fizer isso teve de novo ainda essa
semana se você fizer isso no facebook
clique gostei mar com amigos que gosta
de algum desses homicídios lá nos
comentários no facebook sem mácula ele
me total incluindo kaká capotanço
enquete porque é engraçado
muito obrigado a assistir esse vídeo
aqui um beijão gostoso né sua boca e
deliciosa mesmo que você seja macho eu
te amo um beijo